The master chief was enhanced
and trained for one purpose
to win this war covenant forces appear
to be excavating some kind of object
when i touched the object i felt something
hello master chief i'm cortana master
chief recovered something sacred ring halo
find the halo win the war
Welcome back everyone this is going to be my halo
trailer video that's right there's a new halo tv
series you've probably heard about you probably
seen a couple of the trailers so far we'll break
it down there's a bunch of easter eggs and i'll
explain how this is connected to the games and
what they're doing from the game story because
even if you don't know all the halo lore or like
the complete story of the series you probably
played at least one of the games at some point
if you're brand new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get the episodes i will do a full
video for episode one and we'll see how everybody
likes it and if everybody's really down for it
then i'll do videos for all the episodes but
it'll be 10 episodes total it's starting march
24th which was my prediction that it would start
right before marvel's moon knight series and i
will be doing full moon knight episodes too we
also get our first look at the version of cortana
that they're going to do on the tv show it's being
played by the same actress who does cortana in the
video game so there should be some parody she does
look pretty close to the video game version to
make another marvel iron man comparison she's kind
of like jarvis and friday even though she is an ai
she is a huge character within the story but as
you can see from the general gist of the trailer
it looks like the tv show is taking place during
the events of the first game halo combat evolved
with master chief learning about the existence of
the halo array the halo ring for the first time
in season one will basically be the story of them
just trying to find the ring while also trying to
fight off the covenant if you just bought halo
infinite or you've been watching halo infinite
videos that game takes place much further forward
in the timeline from when what's happening in the
tv show will be happening what i'll do is i'll
explain the halo lore like the overarching story
and then i'll explain throughout the trailer here
in these scenes what they're changing and what
they're adding in the tv show is taking place in
what they're calling the silver timeline because
there's a couple additions like this character
here is not from the game so there'll be a couple
minor additions and a couple things they probably
will not do from the game's story but the main
character you all know master chief also known
by his designation john 117 that's why it has
the 117 on his arm there the number designation
he was given when dr catherine halsey played by
natasha leone here in lieutenant jacob keys this
guy here selected him for their spartan 2 program
their version of a super soldier program very much
in the vein of the marvel captain america super
soldier program catherine halsey is meant to be a
good character mostly like you get that vibe from
the trailer but she did a lot of messed up things
to create these super soldiers the military did a
lot of messed up things to them what does one do
with a superhuman you're not sure you can trust
it's very gray morality because humanity is
under the threat of annihilation from the
covenant so they have to come up with these super
soldiers as a last-ditch effort to fight them off
they had master chief and all the other test
subjects abducted when they were children and
replaced them with flash clones genetically
programmed to die soon after so that their
families would think that they died and
wouldn't come looking for them while the
military modified them they trained master chief
and the other test subjects to about the age of 14
that's when they gave them all their genetic
modifications all their enhancements in the games
master chief is supposed to be the only person
who survived the process of enhancement but on
the tv show it sounds like they're saying that
a couple other spartans survived like you have
bokeen woodbine's character talking about what
they did to us quote unquote so that's one of
the minor changes from the video game story
there are multiple spartans their enhanced
abilities are very much in the vein of marvel's
captain america enhanced strength speed agility
most of their bones are nearly unbreakable just
super soldiers all around you get a little bit of
that vibe during their fighting scenes here with
the covenant soldiers the present day of the halo
universe is about 300 years in our future during
the mid-2500s earth still exists and the human
civilization is embroiled in a long-running
war with a collection of alien species called
the covenant these aliens here although there are
many different races that make up the covenant
they're trying to eradicate humans because they
believe humans are capable of interacting with and
activating forerunner technology this stuff here
that you see master chief interacting with this
long dead highly advanced race that inhabited the
universe leaving behind vastly superior technology
like the halo arrays we talk about them as halo
rings because it looks like a giant ring but the
technical term is halo array there are many of
them that exist around the galaxy and for the
most part the story of the series the story of the
games all takes place contained within the milky
way galaxy the covenant acts more like a cult
who worship the forerunners as their gods their
leaders are called prophets they usually go around
the galaxy forcing other alien races to join them
humans surrender to the covenant they spend
countless years traveling around the universe
looking for forerunner artifacts and technology to
collect but their alien races were not capable of
activating any of the technology the forerunners
purposefully chose humans as their successors
as guardians of all life in the galaxy so they
made it so that only humans could interact
with their tech that's why you see master chief
touching this forerunner artifact and he's able to
activate it like he says in the trailer i touched
it and something happened it changed me the four
runners died out millions of years ago killed by
a race called the flood who is actually the real
main villain of the earlier game story the earlier
part of the story just in general i'll explain the
flood in a second too but it sounds like the flood
won't be the main villain during season one it'll
mostly just be humans versus the covenant in the
search for the halo ring so they probably won't
cover the entire backstory on the forerunners
during season one we'll probably get some of it
as they start to learn more about the forerunner
technology going to look for the halo ring
but millions of years ago the forerunners were
the most advanced species they controlled a
massive part of the milky way galaxy earth's
galaxy and at the time there was an ancient
version of humanity that existed in a much more
advanced form and began this war with the flood
that war pushed them into forerunner territory
but the forerunners took it as a hostile act
by ancient humans and used their technology to
de-evolve humans back to stone age levels and
send them back to earth but because the advanced
humans were no longer fighting the flood off
the flood later began to eradicate the far runners
and the flood is like the sentient plague like a
sentient zombie virus that mutates everything
all life the flood is actually a mutated version
of the original race that seated all life
in the milky way galaxy and that's called
the precursors in the halo lore the precursors
created the forerunners they created humans every
race they seeded the entire milky way galaxy
with life you could think of the precursors as
being kind of like marvel celestials if you just
saw the eternals movie like these original super
powerful life forms once each species around the
galaxy evolved to a certain point the precursors
would judge whether or not they were worthy
of accepting the mantle of responsibility for
managing the galaxy for keeping everything
running being good custodians of reality
in existence for all races just in general of the
races of the galaxy the forerunners evolved first
so the precursors selected them for the mantle
of leadership but then some time later judge them
unworthy and we're going to wipe out their race
and start over again like in the marvel movies
you see celestials using the infinity stones to
judge races and wipe out all life on a planet
they were going to do that to the forerunners
the forerunners rebelled against them and killed
most of the precursors their creators and then
stored their genetic code for future use later
they tried to revive the precursor species but the
test subjects became mutated and turned into the
flood so the flood is kind of like a perverted
mutated form of the precursor original species
sensing they had massively screwed themselves the
form runners then created the massive halo array
rings all over the galaxy which are like massive
reset buttons for all life in the galaxy what
would happen is at first the halo ring would fire
these giant pulses all over the galaxy destroying
all life cutting off the flood's food source then
after the flood had died out the forerunners had
equipped their special arcs with genetic templates
for all the necessary life forms to re-seed the
galaxy with life finishing the reboot the reset
process on the galaxy the forerunners also created
something called the ark which is sort of like the
one ring of power one ring to rule them all the
ark can actually fire all the halo rings around
the galaxy simultaneously because it sounds like
season one of the series is mostly going to be
them searching for one halo ring before they
learn about the existence of many other halo rings
we probably won't learn about the ark till maybe
like season two but millions of years ago the
forerunner's plan kind of works the galaxy gets
a partial reset until millions of years later
species like the covenant humans have evolved
again to the point where they're spreading around
the galaxy and the flood has enough food source
to become a huge threat again spreading around the
galaxy again but at least at the beginning of the
series the way they're playing all these scenes
in the trailers at this point in the timeline
humans in the covenant are mostly focused on their
war with each other and not really thinking about
the flood humans have not learned about the halo
rings yet they're not sure why the covenant wants
to eradicate them yet so neither one of them are
really thinking about the flood so that's why i
say that flood might not actually become a huge
part of the tv series till season two or season
three depending on how they pace the story out but
ultimately the flood becomes a much bigger villain
the main idea being that eventually the covenant
and humans will have to band together to fight the
flood off and stop them from consuming all life
but on separate sides you have other factions
of humans and other factions of the covenant who
want the power of the forerunners the halo rings
for themselves like not all humans are good and
not all covenant or bad i know a lot of you are
probably asking about the arbiter because he's
like one of the other major characters of the
halo series i checked the imdb list and i didn't
see anyone listed as playing the arbiter the main
covenant character that you play as during halo
2 so either they're keeping him secret before
episodes drop or we won't meet him till season
two but episode one will drop march 24th is a
thursday show ten episodes like i said that'll
start right before marvel's moon knight episodes
i will be doing weekly episode videos for that as
well what'll happen is i'll do that halo episode 1
video and we'll just see how everybody responds
to it if it's popular enough i'll keep doing
videos for all the episodes if you have any other
questions about what's going on with the series or
just halo lore in history in general just write it
below in the comments and i'll try to address it
everyone click here for my brand new marvel moon
knight trailer video and click here to learn about
the new joker 2 movie that warner brothers in
dc are working on that's right joker sequel
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!